let's talk a little bit about the lesser
characters of blood-borne their stories
aren't quite as powerful as some of the
characters that I've covered in prepare
to cry but there are so many fascinating
details within their quest lines most of
which you probably didn't even come
across because these stories are really
quite hidden here are ten of them let me
know if you found them this is the
narrow minded man who goes to oedon
chapel if you tell him to go to Youssef
cos clinic he does the exact opposite of
everything you tell him to do but I
think he's interesting because I'm
confident that the exact opposite of
everything he says is true I'll spare
you one nugget of advice
beware the lady of the night she deeply
resents the young sight she is people
whisper she knows what people think of
him yes she despises the saint for
having what she doesn't
truth is it's the other way around Adela
the blood Saint that you saved from
yah-ha Ghul appears to despise ariana
the [ __ ] whenever you talk to Ariana
you can actually see Adela at
eavesdropping on you from the other side
of the chapel it's quite creepy actually
look at her anyway these characters have
something in common and it's that they
both offer you their blood in some sort
of gratitude for saving them if you
accept Ariana's blood it reads a member
of the old healing Church would know
that her blood is similar indeed to
precisely what was once forbidden
adela watches you accepting Ariana's
blood
the jealousy building up inside of her
imagine she's watching her Savior except
forbidden blood over her own she has
this gratitude to you for saving her but
what you're doing is a great sin in her
eyes and eventually it becomes too much
if you take Ariana's blood more than
three times before the Blood Moon then
you explode just kidding
why did I explode there I don't know the
lore on that one anyway I assume it's a
glitch but if you do accept Ariana's
blood more than three times before the
Blood Moon
then Arianna lies dead and the blood is
on Adela's hands literally I take my
blood it got me thinking what could be
so wrong with Ariana's blood what could
be so forbidden about it and now after
working on my last video which was about
cainhurst it becomes pretty clear
Arianna wears a noble dress right and
this is a dress that's worn by the
nobles of the old bloodline that traces
back to cainhurst and cainhurst is the
home to the vilebloods the vampire like
humans that rival the healing Church of
yharnam and as Alfred tells us the
cainhurst vilebloods are born of
forbidden blood that was stolen from
yharnam so somehow Arianna is descended
from the vilebloods and Adela knows it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is the chapel dweller he's one of
the kindest characters in blood-borne
you invite everybody to this sanctuary
because he asked you to and he gets an
immense sense of pride knowing that he
is in some way responsible for the
people's lives here just happy about it
he's all but then you are playing
blood-borne after all so all the
characters in the chapel begin to die
one by one
was he a beast well could someone from
outsider come in and run don't scare me
like that on a knight know this I took
you for a monster oh thank the Stars
you're fairly normal well if you're a
hunter then would you know of any safe
havens first to die the narrow-minded
man then the old woman then Adela then
the dweller and finally Ariana confront
the beggar at any point during all of
this and he transforms in Jewish
you drink the blood of off the town are
nervous and boosts you focus it's better
to send this guy to Yusef cos clinic
instead where he meets a bit more of a
celestial fate in fact Yusef cos clinic
by this point in the game isn't actually
run by the real Yusef qey anymore a keen
player might have noticed what changes
are you out on the hunt then I'm very
sorry but I cannot open this door I am
Yousef Kerr the patients here in my
clinic must not be exposed to infection
I know that you hunt for us for our town
but I'm sorry I pray for your safety oh
well hello splendid let me ask you a
small kindness you're soon off to hunt I
presume then if you find any survivors
tell them to seek your self cos clinic
upon my Hippocratic oath if they are yet
human I will look after them perhaps
even cure them this sickness these
beasts they are not to be feared
this time the night is long I may be
trapped here but I should do something
to help
I even offer a reward for your
cooperation tempt it the real Youssef
kheh is this kind-hearted woman who
treats a few patients at her clinic and
absolutely refuses to open the door for
it would put her patients at risk of
catching the scourge note how she
doesn't want anyone else to enter her
clinic but this all changes once he went
to Cathedral Ward and we never hear from
the real yes Africa a
again if you enter the clinic from
behind you discover what became of the
original yes f ker and indeed all the
patients of the clinic if you sent them
here the impostor who is upstairs and
garbed in the white of the choir has
been experimenting on all the humans you
brought here somehow transforming them
into these celestial beings Gascoigne's
daughter Adela Ariana all mutated by
this woman who wants to rise above
humanity's beastly stupidity if you
confront her before the blood moon has
risen then you to engage in fighting but
if you confront her when the blood moon
is in the sky then it's progressing I
see things I knew it I'm different
I know Beast but it proves the time
chosen don't you see how they ride rides
inside my head it's rather rapturous
then moving on to a couple of other
characters that we found in the early
stages of yharnam did any of you guys
actually follow through with the lonely
old woman's quest line she will continue
to curse and blame you for everything
bad that's happening in yharnam but as
time goes on and as you kill more bosses
she starts self-medicating herself with
sedatives to ward off the despair and
she becomes quite delusional
have some patience that will make
everything better if you keep talking to
her then she passes these sedatives on
to you and after accepting three times
she'll run out and go outside to look
for more sedatives it's at this point
that you can talk to the chapel dweller
and discover her fate yo girl you sent
over she's dead
cool stop dude she's murdered outside
next to one of the graves moving on
another NPC who meets a really cruel
fate is Gilbert who he probably forgot
about he was the guy at the start in
central yharnam who offers you advice as
you go through the game he mentions that
he's lucky not to be afflicted by the
plague of beasts and that imbibing the
old blood granted him time unfortunately
for him like many others in the Arnim
his legs are failing him and he waits
out the night of the hunt indoors
offering some advice to passers-by
after killing Gascoigne he gives you the
flame sprayer which a couple of you
might have missed but did you also know
that he turns into a beast after the
blood moon rises apparently he wasn't as
safe as he thought he was after you've
killed vicar Amelia these lit windows
become occupied by patches the spider
patches returns once again with sinister
motives just like before he offers you
up for sacrifice to his god and then
kicks you off a ledge all standard stuff
and as usual when you confront him he
begs your forgiveness now in previous
games after this after you forgive him
for kicking you down a Ledge he usually
becomes a merchant and in blood-borne
you're probably thinking that he doesn't
become a merchant well he does he's just
incredibly difficult to find so he
appears in the chalice dungeons but he's
so difficult to find that I looked for
him for like a solid day and I still
couldn't find him so let me know if you
do in the chalice dungeons he sells
everything that the bath messengers sell
but at a really high price which makes
absolutely no sense for how difficult he
is to find so there's really no reason
to search him out in the chalice
dungeons unless you really really need
some blood vials or something
anyway also in the chalice dungeons is
an item called the ring of betrothal the
ring was once used in the age of the
great ones and it was used in a time
where marriage was a blood contract
because the ring was given to those who
were chosen to bear a special child
so assumedly queen Yanam was once the
holder of this ring because she was a
woman who bored the child of a great one
and you can even take this ring to Queen
Annalise who's the ruler of the
vilebloods you can even propose to your
queen even though she shuts you down
speak not those words we have little
need of a consort such a path would be
like lead to further ruin thou art dear
to us we would see no harm involving and
that's it those are 10 character quest
lines that are slightly hard to follow
the thing is though I didn't really want
this video to be super long so I didn't
include all of their dialogue but in the
description are links to two places one
is to a channel called moonlight
butterfly where you can find all the
dialogue in blood-borne recorded and
categorized and uploaded for you to
enjoy the other location is simply the
effects tree life wiki so you can learn
about how to follow these quest lines
for yourself I recommend you check out
both of these places if you want to
learn more and thanks for watching guys
as a side note I'm kind of thinking of
moving away from blood-borne in the next
few videos I ran this poll on Twitter
and it showed me that not as many
followers as I thought actually owned
blood-borne so maybe we'll move back to
Dark Souls 1 & 2 and some Demon Souls
and branch out a little bit more so
thanks for watching guys anyway and I'll
see you in the next one